- [Jessie] I love you.
- [Roman] I love you too.
- [Mark] All right.
Roman and Jessie, right?
- [Roman] Yes it is, but
everybody calls me Flame.
- [Mark] Flame?
- [Roman] And this is my Harley Quinn.
(Jessie laughs)
- [Mark] Uh, where are you guys from?
- [Roman] She's from Thousand Oaks, I'm
from Agoura Hills.
- [Mark] So kind of West
Valley of Los Angeles.
- Um, yeah. Ventura County.
- [Mark] And, uh, tell
me about your childhood.
You had both your parents, Roman?
- Um, the childhood
would have to start with
I had my mother and my grandfather
and my grandmother. Um, my father
was not in the picture because
my mom, she was obviously partying
and doing drugs and put my dad
in jail for, what is it called?
Child support purposes and to
gain custody of me, so.
I grew up in a nice big mansion house.
My mom's an actress, my grandfather's
a capital venturist, um, until I was 13.
And my mom dated a man who was
involved in some things and sadly
my mom was murdered, but they concluded
it as a suicide in 2011.
From there I started rebelling.
Tattooing my face, thinking it was cool.
Um, going to jail all
the way until I was 18.
Turned 18, met a girl, she was involved
with robbing houses. So she robbed
a bunch of houses. I took the charges.
'Cause she was um, gonna have my kid.
Ended up killing my kid, I did
five in prison, just got out.
And met my beautiful wife, um...
- [Mark] So who killed your child?
- I'm not gonna say that
she did it intentionally,
I'm gonna say that
crystal meth amphetamine
killed our child, 'cause that's what
ultimately was the major problem.
But that's irrelevant because
we're focused on our life now
and we're gonna have a beautiful,
beautiful boy or girl, and...
- [Mark] So you're pregnant, Jessie?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] So back to your
child that you lost.
Someone was giving it crystal meth?
- Um, just out of respect for her,
I try not to, like, talk about that part
'cause it's, um, kinda hurtful.
- [Mark] Understood. No problem.
- But just know that, just know that
everything's supposed to happen
for the reason that it happens, you know.
And, you know, it was meant to happen.
It wasn't like, giving crystal, you know
the person that was pregnant was
injecting crystal.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- And, yeah. It's very unfortunate
but, hey, it built me into the man
that I am today, very strong.
- [Mark] So when did drugs start for you?
- Um, I was 13, I started
smoking weed in jail.
And it may look like, from body language
and whatnot, and that...
Maybe that's just in my head, but
that I have a drug problem.
It's just, the things that I've been
going through recently, in the past
four weeks with this pandemic,
and being out of jail and seeing
the world for what it truly is, um,
it's just the initial shock and
I don't know how to handle that.
I have a lot of like anxiety.
- Yeah.
- That's why my body language looks
the way it does, where it stutters,
where I talk the way
I do, 'cause I have...
I don't really know how to express myself
except through my music.
- [Mark] So you're a musician?
- I am. I'm actually a company owner.
Um, I have a company.
An entertainment company
called Royal Enlightened
Bloodline Entertainment.
And what I'm focused on is enlightening
individuals that are in the dark.
And not so much bragging
or saying I'm better than,
just showing them through expression
and making them feel good that
there's something more to life
than what people think.
'Cause when you start to think,
that's when everything failed.
'Cause if you weren't thinking, if
you were just relaxing and being
the being that we are supposed to be
then, you know, we'd be free.
- [Mark] So, so tell me about your
childhood. Your mom was an actress?
- My mom, she was an actress, model
if you want to put the
labels on occupation.
Um, more so, she was a star.
She was a figure, uh...
A Hollywood figure.
- [Mark] Somebody famous?
- Uh, she was Lost Boys. She was in
Queen of the Damned, uh, she dated
Robert Downey, Jr. Uh, she, who else?
Who was it she dated?
Prince, when he had his
club out in Hollywood.
Um, Joey (unclear) from
the Gambino crime family.
A big producer for MGM
Records and whatnot.
Um, and just because all these, like,
higher up, elite people
doesn't make (unclear)
so it's just, it's something exciting
it's just entertainment, and so
instead of watching movies as a kid
I was behind the scenes helping
write the scripts to movies and
directing and more elite status
behind the scenes, than you know.
So, yes, my mom she's an actress,
my auntie, she's a
photographer as yourself.
Beautiful, beautiful woman, but psychotic
in the brain right now.
I have no idea why, um, nor do I
want to question it, I
just got away from it.
- [Mark] So you're kind
of on your own now?
- No, no. I have God.
- [Mark] You and Jessie are on
your own now it sounds like.
- I have God and Jessie.
- [Mark] So Jessie, what's your story?
You grew up where? In Thousand Oaks?
- Yeah. Um...
I've kind of been through a lot lately
and uh...
- Stuff from your childhood, baby.
Open up a little bit, baby.
- I think, uh...
- It's hard for her to express stuff too.
I usually speak for her, 'cause
I can feel the frequency
vibration from her.
Go ahead, this is your
time. Express yourself
and vent. You know, cry if you have to.
Talk to me, don't talk
to the camera, okay?
(kiss)
It's really hard and this is
a big deal to open up like this.
- [Mark] Here you go.
- Thank you.
(kiss)
- Um...
- For me, you know, just talk to me.
Just talk to me and tell
me about your childhood.
- (exhales)
- I'm a good boy, okay?
- (crying) Well, I was
privileged, I guess.
Um, I grew up in Ventura County.
Blessed to have been raised there,
and I know it.
Um...
I was always so quick to tell everybody
who's from where I'm from
that they are blessed. And that, uh...
This world's hard.
- Baby, talk about your childhood.
What were your likes, just like,
your mom, what did she do?
- [Jessie] Um...
My mom is a hairdresser, and has been
for forty-five years.
Yeah, forty-five years.
- [Roman] And that's where you got
the inspiration to do the cosmetology
and the hairdressing.
- [Jessie] Yeah, I have been
doing hair since I was 13.
Drugs since I was 11.
That's kind of where it all started
So, um...
I mean, the hair kind
of brought out the uh...
Creativity.
So it was more of like an escape
away from the drugs because I made
the drugs more important, I guess.
- [Roman] When you start, it's just
recreation, it's just...
Was there pain behind the
reason why you were doing the drugs?
Like, was there a reason that you
had to escape? Like, if you were
having a great, blessed childhood
then there was no reason to even
escape from nothing, you know?
Or was there more stuff, deeper things
going on, or are you not comfortable
with speaking.
- [Jessie] I'm not really comfortable.
- [Roman] Okay. I respect that.
I would like to hear about that
on the side, because
these are things that,
as my wife, I should even know
about, you know?
I know it's hard to, like,
but you have to allow, like,
the drugs, like, are
just a, like, occupation.
Another person can't look at you and say
"Oh, you do drugs." It's irrelevant.
It's like, "Oh, well, you drink soda."
- Which I've never let happen, really.
I've tried.
- It's easy
(engine rumbling)
- I didn't then.
- I just want to let you know,
there's more to you than,
"Oh, I'm a heroin addict,
or I'm a this addict."
Mind you, she just got sober. Cold turkey.
Four weeks, for our relationship.
And our baby. Cold turkey.
- [Mark] From heroin?
- Fifteen years. She's been slamming
for fifteen years and just stopped
for me. Us, excuse me, that's selfish.
- [Mark] How was that, Jessie?
- (exhales deeply)
- I mean, it's emotional. Very emotional.
And then having to deal with my family
on top of all that.
And the betrayal. I
mean, I'm heart broken.
And today some things were expressed
because I went to jail while
we were in our relationship.
I had to say, this is the
last time I'll say it.
And I found out Jessie cheated on me.
I was in jail. But I forgive her.
I forgive her, 'cause we weren't
so solid in our relationship.
And, you know, I do...
It was both equally a part and
I take full responsibility for my part.
But that's something
that's the biggest thing
I've ever had to do in my life.
Is step up and just be like
"You know what, I forgive you.
'Cause I've been forgiven so many times.
And I got on my hands and knees today
for two hours and screamed to the sky
saying "If there's
anything, a higher power,
I give up all negative, all evil,
all anything. Voodoo,
hexes, anything on me,
I cast it away from me. And I allow
all positivity to bind our relationship."
And then here your friend comes
down the street on a bike,
saying "I have the plan for you,
I have a plan for you, and I met you,
that's why you're very special to me."
- [Mark] So you guys have been
living on the street for how long?
- Well, we're, I really...
- [Mark] Since you've been out of jail?
- No, I really hate to say it like that.
Um, we're not considered like
transient or homeless, um, we're sovereign
and free, but, we have a place to go, uh,
her parents' house. The only reason
I can't go to her parents' house, um...
- Neighbors.
- Well, uh...Be honest, or no?
- I mean, yeah.
- Too personal? Well, her father
and I we didn't really get along.
Only because, I like loud music,
I'm a rapper and he's older and likes
turning down the music, and he
kind of got at me a
little sideways one day
saying "Hey, what do you think
you can just walk all over like
I'm a little bitch?" And,
when I hear that word,
I instantly reacted, and even
though that's her father,
we're men at the end of the day.
And I ended up punching him in his face.
So he forgave me, I forgave him.
I'm just not allowed to go over there.
And we don't need to rely on anybody else,
you know, I'm a freelancer,
I have ways to make money.
I'm also a webmaster. Uh,
computers are my specialty.
Music is my specialty. Operating anything
on a computer, such as businesses,
virtual network programming, uh
phishing, spyware,
anything. Anything you need.
Photo editing.
- [Mark] So, Jessie are you
looking forward to this baby?
This is your first?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you do you know
if it's a boy or a girl?
- Hm-mm.
- [Mark] Have you seen a
doctor yet or anything?
- Hm-mm.
- No, this is very recent.
The lines literally just...
- Yeah.
- And um, you have to stop
- Sorry, I'm sorry
- Really really hurts. Giving me rug burn.
- [Mark] So do you think you'll be
working by the time the baby comes, or
what do you see for your future?
- We're self-employed.
I already started her,
well she's actually unemployed.
- [Mark] What you guys do for money?
- Uh, that's what I, yeah. I make beats,
I freelance, I make websites, I develop
I photo edit, um...
DJ, um...
Right now, I don't have the foundation,
I haven't had the foundation to
even set up anything. I have two phones.
If I were to have three, four days,
I would be set. I would have my own
spot right after that.
So, like, even...Just to be off,
just like four days. Just think clearly.
We've been walking in Tucson.
I had to leave my auntie's house
and go homeless in the state.
Got myself, go us all the way back here.
You know how expensive those tickets are?
And having nothing but just my wordplay.
And you know what got us here?
Honesty. Truth.
It was, that's what go us here.
'Cause if you're manipulative
and you try to manipulate or finagle, and
people notice that, they
smell that instantly.
And I'm grateful that we're on
this path that we're on.
Honesty and truth and integrity.
I know it's getting a little
bit more deeper than expected.
- [Mark] So, Roman, do you, so you're mom
is dead or she's alive?
- You have to cut that out. Please.
Yeah. Or stop right, we gotta stop...
- [Mark] All right. I'll edit that out.
- Mmm.
- Yeah, that's personal for you to know.
Sorry.
- [Mark] And, uh...
So where do you see, you think
you'll settle down in Los Angeles,
or where will you go?
- Well, hopefully after today, like,
I'm willing, I'm wanting to collaborate
with whatever, I don't know specifically
what it is that you
have done this thing on.
Like if you do photography, interviewing,
I don't know what it's for
or the content of it all.
Nor do I care, 'cause you
opened your studio to us.
I would just like to settle down.
Well, we've already settled down
where we need to, it's right here.
It's where everyone
needs to settle down at.
In the heart.
- [Mark] So are you
guys still using, so...
- No we're not using drugs.
- [Mark] Not using anything right now?
- No. Um, I smoke weed.
- Yeah.
- I do things, uh, it's in the bathroom,
and it's my business, you know.
Every once in a while to do my music
and take away the stress from, um...
The thing we had to deal with today. Um...
You know, I act like I have it
all figured out, but I don't man.
(crying)
I act like I have it all figured out,
but I don't. I really don't.
I don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about.
I don't like, I don't know if
we're gonna like I said be down here
or there, I'm just tired, I'm tired,
I'm tired of being lost. Tired of it.
I'm tired of it. I'm tired of it.
I got blisters on my feet,
my own blood kicked me out of
a different state, I don't even know.
The gang's are way worse out there, dude.
And, like I don't want
her involved with that.
It's not fair to have my girlfriend
who's pregnant walking down the street
where there's human trafficking.
You know how scary that is?
Not only for me but for her.
I have to joke around and be like
"Oh, these guys are gonna
try to pimp you out."
The one guy, he's like "Yeah,
you guys can stay in our motel room."
And when I got into
the motel room, he said
"Oh what do you need, da da da"
I said, "I don't need anything."
He's like, "Okay, well you guys
can use that bed."
And I was like "Okay."
I was like "I'm gonna go get something"
He was like "You're not leaving.
If you leave, you gotta
leave your bitch here."
I said "Like..."
And mind you, I can't do anything,
this dude's huge, got
three of his homeboys,
I'm in a different state,
and guns are legal out there.
You know how scary that was?
All I could do was make
sarcastic jokes at her,
and she's thinking that I'm playing around
I'm like "Hey, we should go outside
and smoke a cigarette real quick."
It's just scary shit, you know.
And I haven't even been able to
take a deep breath and
even relax or shower.
- [Mark] All right. Well thank you so much
for talking with me, you guys.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] And good luck with your baby
and your futures and wherever
you guys go from here.
(kiss)
- [Roman] (unclear)
- [Mark] Thank you.